hello congratulations congratulations
times two this and Wednesday it's like
thank you so much I mean it um my first
question is actually about both projects
because I was reading about how this and
Wednesday came your way VIA personal
phone calls from Jerry and Tim and you
know they're two completely different
types of creators but I'm wondering if
there's a constant between them that
signals to you that no matter what
project they're working on you have to
sign up and work with them yeah there is
a bit of that there is a bit of that I
was always like I wish I was in a Jerry
Brook I'm a movie I wish I was in the
Jerry Brook and I was like um Tim Burton
and then all of a sudden you know those
those those those
you know chances come your way you know
and I know I I'm always Starstruck you
know I never I'm never kind of like
whatever I'm always like really excited
when people that I love their work
you know think of me about for something
the same thing happened with Stephen
Soderbergh I did three movies with
Stephen Soderbergh and every time he
calls up it was like oh thank you thank
you I just love working with you and
what's great about it is that it's never
it's never disappointed me you know but
it's nothing worse than really admiring
people and then you meet them and go oh
God I wish you really but this never
really happened to me but that would be
awful if it did but um not with the
depoami with with Jerry Bruckheimer was
that I was also a fan of this particular
franchise you know that he that he has
many that he has but um this particular
show of movies were were very I love
them and they read up my alley history
I'm a complete history fanatic uh as are
my children
um and so the whole kind of wrote kind
of like Adventure the kind of you know
there's an Indiana Jones quality to this
show too I have to say you know it's um
and then also getting to play The Not So
Nice character in in it all it's as an
actor it's just fun to do that because
you know you keep it all in in reality
but you're able to kind of
manipulate a little bit more you know
than you would if you're just playing a
good old goody two shoes you know I am
really enjoying that quality of Billy
thus far I I love how she does feel like
the quintessential action adventure
villain that we can have fun watching
being evil but then at the same time
you're adding just enough nuance and
more vulnerable moments to still make us
feel like she's a real person so what
was it like the balance I think I think
that's thank you so much but because
that is important because it's um
you know not people are usually bad for
a reason you know and it's usually
through insecurity fragility or some
something very traumatic that has made
them that way because it's really easy
it's much it's easier and it's much
easier to be nice you know but but she's
a little a little dark and I think it's
you know I'm not going to give too much
away because as the story unfolds in in
our series you kind of get a glimpse of
why she's like that and why this
treasure is so important to her
um which makes sense
um so she the right the webs we call
them the writers of the original movies
and of our show
um created really great characters not
for me but for everybody
um they didn't decide oh
20 years on what about National Treasure
let's just make an old TV show about
that they really took the the Beauty and
the love and you know and and the
greatness of that of those two movies
and really rooted it with some really
great characters of today of a Young
Generation that are on the hunt for
Treasure or even if they never thought
about looking for Treasure are really
into it Escape rooms and treasure
hunting how cool is that and I think
it's a generational thing you know we we
all would love to find look I watched
the Antiques Road show all the time you
know I want to be that person who found
his grandmother's
suitcase in the attic and inside was the
missing documentation of the Magna Carta
you know that's I want I want to be that
person and so I have my kind of fix
doing this this show of it could happen
I couldn't find it if I watch Tick Tock
videos of people like finding like
secret rooms in their homes and like
finding safes in there I'm like why
doesn't that happen to me it's worth 20
million dollars you know it's like and
then they go I'll never sell it you're
right
they're kicking me out of here thank you
so much and again congratulations times
two you are keeping me very very happy
at the end of this year thank you so
much